should have listened to Trump that's the
focus of tonight's angle
[Music]
now when President Donald Trump speaking
at the U.N warned Germany and the rest
of Europe about becoming too reliant on
Russian energy remember they literally
laughed at him
Germany will become totally dependent
on Russian energy
if it does not immediately change course
we are committed
to maintaining our independence
from the encroachment
of expansionist foreign powers cut that
out
of course when Russia invaded Ukraine
and sanctions against Russia were put in
place we saw Trump was right now don't
forget how at the time president Trump
was criticized non-stop by our press his
America First views including his
demands that Europe start paying more
for their own defense were slammed by
European leaders especially the
globalist Emmanuel macron
patriotism is the exact opposite of
nationalism nationalism is a betrayal of
it
our interest first and who cares about
the rest you wipe out what's most
valuable about a nation it's moral
values
now just as Obama years earlier had
dismissed the idea of American
exceptionalism macron like Merkel of
Germany he was repulsed by Trump's
anti-globalist message and of course
most of the press Corps agreed
wholeheartedly
to them Trump was the epitome of the
Ugly American and Biden's election was a
huge relief
so the Democratic World briefed a sigh
of relief that that Joe Biden is there
and and the U.S gets ready to be
welcomed back into the Democratic fold
it's been such a great relief the world
over that he has been defeated in the
Joe Biden has been elected president of
the United States a huge sense of relief
in European capitals Europe has a real
friend again in the White House of
course Europe was ecstatic about Biden
because they knew they could roll him
and they could continue free riding on
our military budget and even side with
our adversary with impunity
which brings us to current day where
that exact scenario is playing out
and tonight I'm going to say it's
official that cute little Frenchman has
a man crush French president Emmanuel
macron had a long date with President XI
this past weekend and it was a whirlwind
romance in Beijing and although no
specific commitments were announced
things move very fast
but I guess when you know you know right
and the affair even ended with a big
promo video
foreign
very exciting and then macron let it be
known that France needed to break free
from its old monogamous relationship
with America
now when he was asked about supporting
our efforts to defend Taiwan should
China decide to invade the little chap
answered with a question
is it in our interest to accelerate a
crisis with Taiwan
no he said urging Europe not to become
followers of ours on the China question
well the truth is for some time little
Emanuel has been arguing for autonomy
for Europe basically for his entire
tenure now
now if only he meant it if only Europe
could be self-sufficient we could have
saved what 200 billion dollars that
we've now blown in Ukraine to basically
create a standoff with Russia
but as it stands now Joe Biden's foreign
policy is the definition of insanity now
just as Trump predicted it is illogical
and self-defeating
first we're spending a fortune in a
proxy war with Ukraine carrying the
Lion's Share of the burden against
Russia
second we continue to demand nothing but
love from Europe in return
third we say nothing publicly when
macron stabs Us in the face over China
and Taiwan
fourth we continue to make China Rich by
trading with them as a most favored
nation
and fifth China's massive trade surplus
with us helps them continue their
military buildup which is threatening a
military takeover of Taiwan
sixth our own military leaders are
doubting our ability to defend Taiwan
so I ask you tonight how does any of
this make any sense
now remember with great Fanfare Biden
thought that he could build a new
alliance with Europe by essentially just
sucking up to them
when autocrats are challenging the very
foundations of a rule-based order the
strength of the transatlantic Alliance
and America's commitment to Nato is more
important than it ever been our alliance
is closer than ever
it is more united than ever
he was wrong republicans in Congress can
certainly vote to keep funding the
defense of Europe but they shouldn't
ever expect that Europe is going to do
any anything for us in return
it is literally a gift from the American
taxpayers to a continent that has just
come to hate us and there's absolutely
no point at all as we're analyzing any
of this of blaming macron why blame him
the we want is just telling us all
finally the truth
Europeans do not care that China has
become in many ways more powerful than
the United States in fact they seem to
welcome it because they think it gives
them more leverage over us
the fact that macron is making all of
this clear the angle thinks is a good
thing not a bad thing
it's better to know the truth now than
to build a foreign policy on the hopes
that somehow we're going to get all this
support from Europe only to be
disappointed when the crisis comes but
now we know
France has given China a green light to
take Taiwan whenever it wants
now we need to make our own choices
about what to do between now and then
now beginning way back in 2015 Donald
Trump argued that the big countries of
Western Europe often didn't really act
like allies at all
he pointed out that Europe runs a huge
Trade Surplus with the United States and
that they repeatedly violated their
promise to spend at least 2 percent of
their GDP on defense and of course that
their climate change edicts were harmful
to our interests
what's your biggest competitor the
biggest foe globally right now well I
think we have a lot of foes I think the
European Union is a foe what they do to
us in trade now you wouldn't think of
the European Union but they're a foe in
a trade sense they've really taken
advantage of us
he was a hundred percent right
he knew Europe would never support us
against China
of course when the globalist figurehead
Joe Biden ended up in the White House
the establishment's pro-europe approach
was given another go
and no surprise it has been a total and
complete disaster
Biden gave up most of our trade leverage
dropped tariffs on steel and aluminum
against Europe
he gutted our energy Independence he
rejoined the Paris Accords giving the
Europeans more leverage to push us
around on emissions issues
and despite Biden's claims that he was
going to support more Manufacturing in
America he buckled the moment macron
complained promising to tweak our policy
to help European businesses
Oh and about that trade deficit well
last year our trade deficit in goods
from the EU alone was over 200 billion
dollars for the second year in a row
so it didn't take the ccp's media long
of course to celebrate that propaganda
victory
so the debate over Europe between Trump
and the establishment has now been
settled Trump was right
they don't care about any International
rules-based order if they did they would
not be giving fist bumps to president XI
so no wonder our economy is in so much
trouble no wonder China has overtaken us
as the most powerful country in the
world and no wonder our geopolitical
position has collapsed
our leaders are idealistic morons
and until we get leaders who see the
world as it is not as some globalist
fantasy
president xi's influence will only grow
and that's the angle hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else